Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, known across the
Internet as Rawkode.
Today is another episode of Rawkode Live, a
show where we get hands on with really
cool software
just in general within the cloud native space,
the Kubernetes space, the front end space, the
API space, you name it. And today is
no exception.
Today, we're taking a look at Grafbase.
It is a platform for building GraphQL based
APIs.
Now to join us today and guide us
on our journey is founder and CEO,
Frederick. Hello. How are you?
Hey.
Thanks for having me. No. My pleasure. It's
always a joy for me when there's a
product out there, a piece of software that
I discover and I'm like, I could use
that. And then when we get to do
a session on it, I'm always even more
pumped. And then to top it, the wee
cherry on the cake is this is all
powered by some pretty cool Rust code as
well. So, again, my pleasure. Thank you for
joining me today.
Thanks. Yes. My name is Yeah. Please go
take a minute.
Yeah. Yeah. My name is Frederick. I'm the
founder of Grafbase.
And just one
minute summary of Grafbase. It's a fully managed
GraphQL platform
with a focus on developer experience.
So we
or I I've been using GraphQL almost since
the beginning,
since 2015,
'20 '16. I was previously
the CTO at a company called The RealReal
based in San Francisco,
and we
were building front end experiences
as people do,
web and native iOS and Android. And
we had lots of data silos,
and we were using microservices and rest APIs.
And we discovered GraphQL as a way to
solve some of the challenges that we had,
you know, in terms of optimizing
for a number of requests, only fetching
what the the client needs.
So we we adopted GraphQL early on, and
I've been a fan ever since. When I
left
The RealReal three years ago, I decided to
build
a company called Grafbase,
which is
essentially a developer experience play to build and
deploy GraphQL API similar to what Netafy
and Rawkode have done for the front end
cloud
we are doing for the GraphQL
cloud.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
Let's touch on a few of those points
just because I feel there'll be good context
for the audience.
Now you said the GraphQL solves
a certain subset or a certain set of
challenges, right, that people have with with REST
APIs or REST like APIs.
I definitely feel the the same. I do
not enjoy building CRUD REST style APIs.
GraphQL comes with a type system, which I
think just solves more problems than we get,
but we do get some challenges.
Could
you maybe go into them in a little
bit more details where people struggle with GraphQL
and why they may want to look at
something like Grafbase and what challenges it solves?
Definitely.
So so, I mean, it's fair to say
that starting off building a REST API is
easier.
You can quickly, on any kind of framework
or language, set up a RESTful route.
You have a resource. You know? Typically, it
starts with users or something like that and
go posts, comments, or whatever it is you're
building. And it's it's quite intuitive,
but, you know, it's not documented
most likely. You probably don't have any types
or documentation,
like I said,
and you start building your your front end,
application.
But it's once you start re you know,
querying multiple things, you will make multiple requests
to your API.
So performance suffers
as well as,
fetching the data that you need to display
the page with REST. You know, it varies,
but most likely, you would just fetch the
whole resource
even if you only need a few a
subset of the fields of that resource.
So the payload is also bigger.
And when you start evolving the schema,
you've all seen it, you know, v one,
v two, v three, it's quite painful
to have multiple rest rest
endpoints of the same resource, and, GraphQL
really solves a lot of that. But to
address to address the question,
you know, building GraphQL APIs is has a
steeper learning curve. Right? So
I would say Grafbase helps to
we we want to help address that,
gap essentially where we wanna make it more
accessible to any engineer, but in particularly full
stack front end devs who might be building
a new GraphQL endpoint for their front
end application, and they have a bunch of
data sources that they need to,
you know, they need to fulfill their their
their pages or their screens.
And we
we built
a bunch of features for that. Right? So
one of them is what we call the
connectors
that you can then point
your
configuration
to, let's say, a GraphQL endpoint or an
open API, REST API spec
databases like Mongo or Postgres, and we will
then do a lot of that crowd work
for you. That's quite labor intensive.
But but even, like,
manually creating resolvers and defining types, we built
a an SDK in TypeScript
that makes it a bit easier and less
daunting, I would say.
Yeah. Definitely.
I love you know, you said at the
start, it's focuses on, like, developer experience.
And I think that that really comes through
when you start to play with the product.
And, you know, I have been exploring and
playing with this a few times now for
my own Academy API,
and everything was just really simple. And I
like that even though you built all of
this in Rust,
the TypeScript has the SDK because that's where
the developers are usually building these APIs are.
Right? You've went to them where you're using
I'm assuming, the one who put words in
your mouth. But I'm assuming you use TypeScript
and you didn't get people a Rust SDK
because
those are the people that are in this
space. These are the people that are building
these platforms or APIs. Is is that correct,
or did I just make that up?
No. I mean, it's certainly I would say
we have two kind of primary
audiences that use Grafbase. One is the front
end and mobile developers who
typically build what we call back end for
front end, which is a new GraphQL endpoint
from existing
APIs and data sources.
They really appreciate the TypeScript SDK that it
can live inside the mono repo
with cogeneration
and all of that stuff in one one
place. Right? So it's really great for them.
Then there's kind of the platform teams,
back end teams.
There it varies. You know? I think we
we still support SDL. Right? That's kind of
how we started actually because it is agnostic.
Right?
But who knows? We we might launch Python
and Rust SDKs in the future.
Because another thing we haven't talked about is
the fact that
we we deploy the API itself
to to the edge. Right? The edge the
global edge network of 300 locations
that runs your endpoint in a v eight
isolate.
So we compile from Rust to WebAssembly
to achieve that. Right? So you get if
you think about Lambda, which is like a
serverless function,
but it's globally distributed. So without cold starts,
you get fifteen,
twenty milliseconds response times on a cold boot
for your for your for for all your
users. Right? So it's really, really powerful if
you wanna do authentication,
caching,
personalization,
geo geolocation, that kind of stuff. It can
happen right next to user, and then you
can go back to the origin depending on
what you need to do. So it opens
up to this really cool use cases.
You're just seeing all the right things. I
mean, my favorite three buzzwords are Rust, WebAssembly,
and Edge. So, you know, tick tick and
and tick.
Let's let's touch on the Rust quickly before
oh,
yeah. I mean, I completely overengineering the Rawkode
Academy platform that we're launching. And I just
made this I was like, I'm not gonna
have a server
in AMS 1 or NYC or something like
that. So I want I want it to
run at the edge.
And I just have to know I mentioned
ever since. But I I I I'm not
gonna answer that just now. What I wanna
get into is Rust.
Now, Rust is not an easy language
language to learn. I've been writing Rust for
six or seven years now, and I still
suck at it. However,
I'm curious, did you have any experience with
Rust before going in to write in Grafbase,
or was this your first project, and what
has that learning curve been like if so?
Yeah. Great question. I mean, I I started
prototyping
in TypeScript,
like, sort of three plus years ago
just to get something up and running quickly.
It was, you know, really hacky and
probably I don't wanna share too much of
the of the first version was built, but
but it worked. Right? And then,
like, definitely,
the number one goal was to have something
that was performant,
scalable,
and compiled to WebAssembly
easily. Right? So the tooling for that was
really important. And, of course, something that was
typed,
something that developed like, something I can see
myself writing for the coming ten plus years.
And, you know, this was 2021.
So,
you know, WebAssembly was really mature and Rust
Rust itself was mature and was on the
rise, and it's still on the rise. So
it made a lot of sense for us
to to adopt it. But I've been using
it a bit on the side, honestly,
but my strategy was go out and hire,
like,
a players in the Rust space. Right? So
people who had been building Rust for several
years.
So we brought on really knowledgeable people on
the team, and that's really paid dividends
as we as we built Grafbase.
Awesome.
Love it. And maybe your team are the
people I should be heading up, and I
get stuck with a lifetime issue then because
that seems to happen very regularly.
No. Yes.
Yeah. Thank you for sharing all of that.
It was really interesting. I think now is
the time where we actually stop talking about
how awesome Grafbase is and actually show people
some of the things that they could do
with that. And I think, you know, as
we explore,
if there's any of the questions that people
have in the audience or something you want
to see,
just drop them into the comments. We're always
happy to to tweak things as required.
So let me pull up
my screen share where we have the Grafbase
website. You can find us at graphbase.com.
That is Grafbase, g r a f, base.
And now this is completely
pointless to today's demo. It's something that I
loved, and I don't know
if
it's just something I haven't seen before. But
I'm assuming you've right clicked on your logo
before. Right?
I think, yeah.
There's just this neat feature.
Oh, come on, computer. No. You're not gonna
do it. Oh, there we go.
Yeah. Don't know what's going on with my
computer. Yeah. Where it allows me to download
the icon or the full logo,
which is such such a nice touch.
Those small little details made me smile. I
just thought I would share that, but completely
irrelevant to what we're gonna look at.
So It's the small things in life.
It
was really weird. And again, not that relevant.
But I was exploring using Vivaldi as my
browser
and I right clicked like, I think Grafbase
was the first website I went on to
because I was preparing for this. And I
right clicked, and then I was like, oh,
that's a cool Vivaldi feature. And then it
didn't work in any other website, and then
I realized, oh, you have actually just built
that into your website.
And I was like,
you know, not only do you have a
commitment to the developer experience, but it goes
right across the stack. So
and so from here, what we get back
on track and we'll go to the documentation.
And as always in Rawkode Live, we haven't
really done anything in advance. Although, Frederick was
kind enough to provide a few little bits
of code to get us started. But we're
gonna start from zero and work towards getting
this working.
And we have a pretty cool couple of
things to show in the process.
So
the getting started guide here will guide you
through all the front ends and everything that
you need to know to build your first
API.
You can go to the quick start and
this is one of the things
that confused me first
is that you are
you have a Rust engine and CLI,
but you're
can deliver the binary to people via
NPM. Right?
That that's what's happening here. And that's not
that wasn't something I don't I don't think
I'd actually seen that before until I was
exploring Grafbase.
But I guess, again, it makes sense if
you're working or you're developing people that are
using your product to come from an a
node or TypeScript background. This is a pretty
nice way just to deliver that pain away
to them. I thought that was a nice
touch.
And it it is a thin wrapper on
on top. But but, yeah, NPM is most
people have it installed
whether you're a no developer or not. And
then
we are we are gonna publish to Homebrew
and
crates.i0
as well.
We're gonna resume crates.io.
It stopped
working for a bit, but those will also
be available soon.
Cool. Alright. So people can create their own
Grafbase project with NPS Graphbase then.
Now, let's take a look at what we're
starting at today. So this
well, we start with products.
It should be nice and simple. Right?
Mhmm. Okay.
So we have a package dot JSON
for a products API, and you put in
some of these scripts, which we'll get to
momentarily.
But in order to really kick things off,
this Grafbase is the CLI and this one
here is your TypeScript SDK.
And we have a Grafbase configuration.
So from what I understand from the documentation,
this is how you can spec out and
build a GraphQL API when you want to
start from nothing. This is the kind
of your phase one. Is that right?
Yeah. This is a
I guess we could take a step back
and talk about what
federation is and what a subgraph is,
and then, we can dive into
how to start
composing your schema.
Well, this is the standalone graph. Right? So,
like, there's no concept of federation or effluent
at at the moment.
Yeah. I mean, there's a few things sprinkled
in here that are relevant to federation.
Up top there, you we actually you'd say,
hey. This is a subgraph
in this time alone
arguments. And then
we also add, you know, the key
to the end of the product there. The
key we're saying the field ID is the
key, and that's a concept in federation.
And then we're yeah.
Okay. So Well,
I'll tell you what. Let's I'm gonna break
your example first. Right? Because I always like
to know how these things change things. So
if I remove that, that doesn't break anything.
Correct?
Yeah. That's right. And
we could just comment off the key.
And now we just have a standalone subgraph.
Is that is that correct? Yep. Yep. We
we we just have a a graph well,
we have the potential here to have a
GraphQL API. So let's let's get this working
so that people can see what Grafbase does,
and then then we'll come back to the
code.
Sorry. Sometimes I just like to go off
script and see what happens. But
we have
apps,
reviews. We got the reviews. Right?
Think it's products. Yeah. I
should never trust anything I say.
Now, you've already created those package scripts for
us. So, if I pop this open,
we
oh, wrong one. Let's pop the right one.
And we should be able to run an
NPM install followed by an NPM dev and
we get a GraphQL API.
So, let's just make sure that works.
Let's I don't have PMPM.
Do it this way.
While that runs just in case it's slow,
we did get a question.
Is there an install section and the documentation
for a non NPM install?
I don't think there is.
And, Frederick, can correct me if I'm wrong,
but if you go to GitHub,
Grafbase, Grafbase, there is a releases page with
binaries.
So you can download your binary here.
And you did mention that homebrew and cargo
install
will be options in the future.
Yes. Very soon.
But, yeah, that's a good point.
Yeah. You can download for your architecture
directly from GitHub.
Okay.
So we did that. We can now do
dev.
So
according to the Grafbase CLI, we now have
something running on port 4,001.
So if we jump back to our browser,
we get this user interface,
which has loaded the schema and we can
see that we have products.
And if you're familiar with GraphQL,
I'm assuming we can do product
ID
title.
And on the right, we get a response.
So that right in itself is just magic.
So now we need to show people how
that worked.
Yes.
So
let's go through this. We have a graph
based dot config. T s. And in this,
you're using the graph based TypeScript SDK
where you're saying we want a standalone graph,
an
API as I just call it for now.
You're then defining the types within this API.
So you're saying this is a product and
it has these properties, ID, title, description, and
price.
And then you're defining a query endpoint called
products
which returns
yeah. And I I actually
so you're just using the type. Right? You're
saying you're returning a list of products
and then has a resolver called products.
And we're not gonna touch on authentication or
anything like that right now, so we'll just
ignore this. And then you just export the
config with your graph.
I mean, that's the SDK in a nutshell.
This is how you define what the API
is,
but there is a resolver that we haven't
gotten to yet.
And if I said they're incorrect?
No. No. That's exactly right. I mean, they
they just the point here is this is
a code first
approach. So we're using a builder pattern essentially
to
define
your
schema using TypeScript. Right? So there's two camps.
Some people prefer
schema first.
Most people who are have built larger APIs
use code first, but there's no right or
wrong.
Yeah. I'm definitely an as code or code
first person.
Yeah. To me, it just resonates
better.
I guess one of the questions
I I've got here is like these
this way of describing a type is
very Grafbase specific.
Did you consider using any of the popular
libraries out there like
Zod or Tickbox or everyone that is the
way to scaffold this?
Yeah.
We're we're actually
we're working on opening this up so that
you can use
your own kind of way
of building and defining your schema.
So that's that's coming
coming quite soon as well. So you could
use your own
schema builder, GraphQL library,
and you can then just use the output
of that executable schema to deploy your and
run your graph with Grafbase.
Oh, nice. I like that.
Okay. So let's get back to the fact
that we ran a query and we got
data back.
This data comes from the fact that you
have said that we have some sort of
resolver,
which is just a string called products.
So this is one of the bits of
what Grafbase magic where you correlate the string
to a piece of code. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. So we kind of use the
file system here. Right? So you have
inside the folder resolvers,
which is a predefined
location.
There's a products dot t s file, and
that maps to the name products
that you define up there. And it returns
a static list of three products.
Awesome.
Now I guess this is just
TypeScript code. So while
a static array of data has been returned.
This could quite easily be executing SQL queries
against the database, MongoDB,
other GraphQL APIs, REST APIs, etcetera. Like, this
is where
you connect Grafbase
to your data model and
make things work.
Yeah. Yes. Exactly right.
And you can create as many resolvers as
you want. Right? So what we do under
the hood
similar to, let's say, Vercel, is we take
these
resolver functions. We bundle them, and then we
deploy them to its isolated
to to a v eight isolate, essentially, so
that whenever Quest comes in,
it gets run-in
in isolation.
So it's really, really fast and low latency.
Nice.
And it definitely sounds like we could have
an entire episode where we just talk about
that deployment model and how you're doing that
because there's a lot of interesting stuff there.
But but focus
on the code aspect for today.
So
we have products. And then if we take
a look at reviews,
it's pretty much the same.
Oh, they said they actually have they share
a type. Right?
Exactly. So this is another
standalone
subgraph,
and then the different it defines re the
review type, obviously. And what you do is
you open up
the product type, and this is where federation
comes in. You can then say, hey. On
the product type, I wanna add a reviews
field,
which then resolves
from the reviews resolver in this subgraph.
Neat.
Okay. Let's get back to this because we've
got something over here.
I removed the key here and the subgraph,
and we still got an API that worked,
resolved, that gave us data.
So I wanna bring back each of these
and talk about what that changes. So if
we bring back subgraph true,
what does this indicate to the Grafbase engine?
What does it tell it, and how does
it change the behavior?
Yeah.
So
the if you if you if you enable
subgraph behavior, you essentially expose
two
field
two fields two clear fields
that that are needed for
for kind of federated
queries to happen. Right? So there's a service
underscore service and underscore entities
query in there that's
that's that's required for this function properly.
You could see it. And if you enable
this and you open up Pathfinder again, Pathfinder
is our,
you know, in house GraphQL explorer we built.
Does that real oh, that reloads.
Yes.
So if you refresh the screen
I'll restart the Oh, yeah. You need sorry.
Yeah. You need to add ID as well.
Otherwise Alright. Okay. It it it needs at
at least one key
directive.
Yeah. There you go.
K. It detects the change,
and we have to They use either. Yeah.
Okay. So
what does the key do then?
So if you go
yeah. So the so the key essentially is
something that is needed to correlate
two types. Right? So if you wanna do
you know, if you're if you're querying
for products
and you wanna get reviews,
the the
the gateway
the federated gateway needs to know, okay.
How how do I join these essentially? Okay.
So you're kind of indicating that the ID
is the primary key of this type. Yes.
Exactly. If we go back to the
reviews one,
This also has an ID, but that's not
mentioned here because it just gets it from
the schema itself.
Yeah. Yeah. Because the, yeah, the the the
gateway already knows how to resolve products from
the product service,
but reviews will come from the review subgraph.
Okay. That makes sense.
Cool.
Alright.
So
I'm always curious just what's happening under the
hood. Like,
I need to see what these do.
K. So this returns
the STL.
Go figure. And
entities.
This looks like something to do with Grafgel
fragments,
is definitely not my strong suit, but
let's see what happens.
I guess that does something different.
Alright. Yeah. I don't understand what the entity's
endpoint is for.
But I'm assuming that's just the way that
the federated graph gets more information.
Yeah. Yeah. It's it's a different way of
introspecting
a subgraph essentially.
Alright. Okay. Gotcha.
So if we
you've already provided
know why my alt tab keeps going to
not where I want it to go. But
you've already provided a top level
package dot JSON where we can run PMPM
dev,
which will spin up everything together including the
federation, which we haven't looked at yet.
But let's do that
dev.
And
what this is doing is running each of
those graphs on their own
port,
but the federation one will delegate requests for
the types to the correct API, if I'm
not mistaken.
So
I'm assuming gateway on port 4,000 is where
we want to be.
Yeah.
That's my own API.
So, yeah, so now this is a
this is a clean slate. Right? So the
federated graph
has no no subgraphs.
No subgraphs have been published yet.
So the schema's empty.
So now what you need to do is
publish
the product graph first and then reviews, and
we can
we can look at the the schema after
that.
Right. Gotcha. Okay. So let's take a look
at the gateway first and then we can
publish to the gateway.
So this also has a Grafbase config where
we're saying that this is a federated one
and there's no other
there's nothing here that sells it where it's
reaching out to, which is why the schema
is empty. We have to
publish each individual graph to the federated graph
for it to be consumed.
So if we come over here,
we'll do product.
And it was
PMPM
publish dev,
I believe. Call on dev. Yep. K. That's
right.
This runs a Grafbase
publish
dev,
goes to the name of products and tells
it where to find that
API.
And if we come back to reviews
and do the same. May
maybe first, maybe we'll go back to Pathfinder
just so you can see the kind of
the progression.
So if you go to the schema page
where you can see the SDL,
there's yeah. There you go. So there you
can see product
and the query the products query. Right? One
sub graph. Makes sense?
Yeah. So we could start to query this
now.
Like so.
Alright. So now you're in team b,
and you wanna create your reviews
subgraph
that you publish to the federated graph without
touching
team a's code base.
So this is what this enables, essentially.
So let's go back to schema,
and now we have review.
And, also, you can see on the product
type, you can see the reviews field,
which will then resolve to the reviews of
Graf. And this is really Oh, we have
a good idea.
You've actually extended this type?
Yes.
Ah, I I didn't I didn't appreciate that
from the
the code. Let's look at that again.
And then on the config. Okay. So
team b has said, hey,
We wanna add something to product, and we
wanna make our reviews queryable from it.
That's nifty. I I didn't that that skipped
over me, and I've got a nice little
smile on my face now. So I like
that.
Yeah. These are the kind of moments that
make you appreciate
Grafge even more.
Alright. So let's
get reviews,
and we'll get content
and rating.
Wow. Look at that.
That's nice.
And then, you know, as you see this,
you you can then imagine, you know, engineering
teams,
two hundred or even thousands of engineers
collaborating on a super graph or a federated
graph
in Synchrony. You know? And this is what
this unlocks, and we can we can look
at things later. There's, you know, schema checks
that is essentially something you add for CICD
to make sure that what you're about to
publish
will be composable.
And there's a linting, and then there's operation
checks and all that stuff to make
to make this more seamless
for large teams.
Okay.
Now that you've
made me smile and be confused at the
same time, but I'm happy confused.
I'm really curious about this extension point because
one of the things I'm doing with the
Rawkode Academy API, like I said, WebAssembly,
Edge, and Rust,
is that I'm trying to get into position
where every like, it's not microservices.
It's literally every everything I deploy is like
a type.
And rather than me
changing
or doing migrations,
I'm using new services
to deploy new functionality and then trying to
bring all that data together at the front
end, which is why I was interested in
Grafbase in the first place.
But what I didn't appreciate is that I
could just take this type here. So I
wanna
I wanna copy your review service and tweak
it. And I'm curious, can we add arbitrary
scalars to the product rather than a type
preference? Would that still work?
Custom scalars is still work in progress. It's
coming.
Oh, just well, if I wanted add a
string or an integer.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Sure. I mean,
go ahead and add.
Okay. So one of the use cases I've
got is, like, you know, say I have
you know, I I model my YouTube channel
on my on my type. So say I
have something called a livestream, and then I
decide I want to add a field to
that livestream. I'm very much trying to be
very particular about not adding migrations. I I
don't wanna get into migrations whatsoever.
But I could do this with a new
service that just injects,
Say it was a
thumbnail URL and I wanna add that. So
let's just let's just do it and see
if it works the way I think it
does because that would be really cool for
me.
Let's copy reviews and we'll call this
what else do products have?
We'll call it link. Right? This is our
link service.
And I'll delete the Grafbase.Directrix.
I think that may cause issues.
I'll change this to be link
and I'll give it a new port
like so.
And
we'll modify this. You wanna
change the name too in the published script.
The name of the subgraph.
Alright. Let's get there.
And I'm gonna do g dot string
like this.
And that you're you're saying this will allow
me to enrich that type with a new
value, which is very nice.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you'll need a resolver.
Mhmm. I mean, sure. In this case, it's
just an empty string. You could do that
too. But, typically, you have a you'll want
a resolver to return some data for that
field.
Okay. So link.
I'll gokagi.com,
Google
Com,
and we'd be remiss if we don't do
graphbased.com.
So
this isn't going to be a review. This
is now
a well, I guess this is just going
to be a link. Right? And
Yeah. Okay. Well, I guess it depends what
you if you wanna create a link object,
which is typically I recommend doing that.
Like, try to think of everything as types
or entities rather than just a string.
Okay. So we would have something like this.
Mhmm.
You know, just in the sake of completeness,
let's not leave any sort of whole thing.
Does that change my config then?
Or does this still Yep.
Just have a reference to my link object.
Right?
Exactly.
So you could
you need to define a,
up top, you know, a a link type,
a reference here.
Link.
And I'll need to rename that fail.
So I need to
type. Okay.
Link.
Alright.
So
with this resolver
What's
Is is it sorry. Is it a list
or maybe you wanna omit? Is it just
one link?
Maybe I wanna omit the list or not.
Yeah. It's just it's just one. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. So I guess what I I'm curious,
right, is
how does it connect?
Oh, yeah. Because you got the idea of
key,
but I'm assuming the link
I'm confusing myself now. I'm wishing I hadn't
gone down this path. This ID here, is
this the product ID or the link ID?
This is the link ID.
Okay. So how does this resolver know to
fetch links for the product?
Yeah. So, you know, in the resolver
function signature, you have four.
The fur first thing is the root to
the parent, and in there, you could then
get the
roots
the calling, you know,
types ID. So you could you could kind
of deconstruct
here and just get ID if you wanted
to, and then you can use that to
fetch links for that product. Right? Okay. So
let's assume
someone's interest has peaked here. I I I
assume they are for sure. And they wanna
know how they work out what that signature
is from the documentation.
How how how do they get that? Resolvers
on the left. Mhmm. Section overview.
And here should be an example
somewhere.
Oh, yeah. Resolver function. Okay.
Rx in context.
Okay.
Right. Okay. Got it. So I'm assuming this
is kind of what we're trying to do
with the root and then extracting a value?
Yep.
Right.
Okay. So we pull that to.
So what's RxN? Sorry.
So so I guess it like, you think
about, like, root in this case,
you
have a product type. Right? So
the
link field is gonna get called from
the product type. So root
will have, you know, existing fields in there.
Right? So you have the ID, for example.
So that's gonna get passed in the root.
Args
is if you have
query,
like, if there were arguments to this link
field, let's say
I don't know. Maybe if Like, if we
touch something here where we said filter
name. Well,
but on the link
on the link field, for example.
Yeah. Like, that that would be for the
product's
resolver. You would get the args, and that's
the second.
Okay. So we can do something here equals
root,
and we're trying to fetch at the ID.
And you said that comes
I mean, would that just work?
Yeah. Yeah. You could deconstruct it there or
write in the signature itself.
Yeah. You could do that.
I'll leave it like this. Yeah.
Sure.
And I'm gonna get really nasty now. Right?
So
if I d equals one,
I'll assume it's gonna be a string.
Yes.
Which means we can remove the I d
from our I mean, it doesn't really have
to be a type now, but I I
guess
Oh, the link type is nice to have
an interface up there, I think.
Alright. I'll I'll remove the ID because I
don't think we need to, and we'll just
put URL. Okay.
And we'll have URL.
I'm sure people are watching me going, what
the hell is this idiot doing? But
we started.
I I feel like I need to do
it. The first
this is how database
this is why they haven't even started many
years ago.
So
alright.
Now we don't now we could just return.
You you get nothing.
So
this is a very crude resolver,
and it's returning a link. Can I annotate
that?
No.
Well,
we we do we can look at this
later if you want. There is a in
docs, there is this code gen,
experimental code generation
that allows you to do kind of strongly
typed resolvers.
Well yeah. I was just curious because my
interface is now unused.
So, I mean, I can just do this.
But
Yeah. Sure. You don't need to do it.
So let's go back to my madness over
here
where we have a URL
that's disappears
and this gets resolved with our resolver.
I I think you do need ID.
Because of the key. Otherwise,
the key will yeah. It will complain.
But
yeah.
I mean, does
it have to be unique? No. No.
I don't think so. No.
If this doesn't work, I'm very sorry. But
I was following a train of thought. So
But you need to also update the type
definition in the config. You need to add
ID there
to the yeah. Gotcha.
And then in the before you publish that,
go to the
package
script as well because it I think it
has the wrong name. No. I changed it.
Yeah. There you go. Oh, you did it.
Okay. I missed that. Okay.
So
let's see
what happens. So we can do a PMPM
install,
and we can add this.
Oh, no. We don't have to add it
because you're doing a global PMPM dev. Right?
So
I should be able to just
do PMPM.
I could check PMPM
publish
dev.
Oh, yeah. It's probably just because it's not
started. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Requie the object not defined.
It's still okay.
What?
Oh, yeah. You don't have a you don't
have a query
in here.
But, no, you shouldn't have to.
I don't think we have a query anywhere
else.
No. You're right. Alright. Let's see if my
local check it out on my port. Right?
So
well, that might be an issue. Oh, no.
There we go.
Oh oh, I I know what happened. You
you actually stopped the whole thing. Right? So
if you stop it, the in memory representation
goes away in local devs. So you need
to
start over. So you need to,
you know, publish products, reviews, then link now
that everything is running.
Right. Okay.
We don't persist
the the state.
One link.
Oh. Okay.
I'm just breaking everything today.
There we go.
Alright. Here you go.
Well done.
Complete It worked. Random tangent, but
that is super powerful.
I am so happy and impressed.
And I had no idea that feature existed
whatsoever.
So, yeah, that's amazing.
Alright. Thank you for entertaining me. Let's get
back on track.
So
that's usually powerful.
And let's focus on that use case just
so that it's really cement that into people's
heads.
You're working with a whole bunch of teams.
You're all working towards one API
and, you know, traditional routes would be we
all build our different REST stuff. We stick
an API gateway in front of it and
then we hope that everything works together. But
what Grafbase is doing is different. The teams
are independently working on their own small little
part of a made
global graph, their own subgraph,
to find in their own types, their own
resolvers, and we're getting data.
They can then take their graphs that they're
happy with, they've tested, all good,
they publish it,
and the federated graph starts to pick all
this up. And we actually seen that in
in progress. Right? We published one. We checked
the schema. We published one. We checked the
schema. We're enriching it all the time.
Then there was the tangent. Okay. We realized
these subgraphs can actually extend other parts of
the graph.
I'm
assuming there's a schema registry that if my
link service tried to add ratings
or reviews,
we would get that error during publish and
say, sorry, you can't do this. This this
already exists.
That workflow
has gotta be an enabler for teams. It's
gotta be able they've gotta be able to
increase their velocity. They don't have to
worry too much about stepping on each other's
toes because
the graph consolidation,
the schema, all of that works together to
give them something that is guaranteed to be
correct or it'll fail to publish. Again, I
don't wanna put words in your mouth, but
does that sound correct? Is that what's happening
here?
Absolutely.
I mean, it it's it's exactly right. It's
built with this very use case in mind
where
your team evolves from
one monolithic
code base and graph into
multiple subgraphs. And
it's really, really nice to have some guardrails
around that and during CICD catch
issues so that when it goes to production,
you have confidence that
it should work. You know?
Okay. You mentioned CITD.
Well, I think that loops us nicely into
let's get this into
production.
And,
we could
repeat
those
published steps that we've done, but you actually
have an integration with GitHub to automate this
for people. Right?
Yes.
Exactly.
Okay. So I guess the first thing I
need to do is,
you know, we can stop testing this. We're
happy with it. I'll even just kind of
shut this window down.
We're in the top level.
I can just do my YOLO commit. In
fact, my workspace, has that got a wildcard
in it? Yeah. Cool. I was wondering how
that worked there.
We could do get in it.
Get at
ship being dot one. Right? This is it.
We're gonna start making money.
And I can push this.
Remote
l s.
Oh, list.
Why can I never remember how to do
that?
Don't know why I bother trying to use
the get commands.
So this is your upstream which we don't
need
and this is my federation. Okay. So we
can do a get push origin
main.
Now, that's not gonna do anything by default
yet because we've not hooked anything up. But
if we do go to GitHub,
I've got my ship b one here.
Shall we use the the Grafbase UI to
connect this all up and deploy to production?
Let's do it.
So let's sign in
and
create project.
I'm gonna have to adjust my permissions.
Federation demo. So I'm just given the Grafbase
application access
to what we need.
Here's my passkey.
Such a nice upgrade passkey.
Yeah. 100%.
Let's give this a wee refresh.
There we go. So I could just import
this repository.
I've never done this before, I don't know
what this looks like.
Yeah. So the two things to pay attention
to. One is the name of this. Because
I think the first thing you wanna do
is the gateway.
Right? You probably wanna give it federation demo
dash gateway or just the gateway.
Mhmm.
And then the root folder is gonna be
dot slash apps
slash gateway.
And that's it. If you have any end
bars, you can add them here, but we
don't. So go ahead and deploy.
Nice confetti. Confetti.
Yeah. We gotta celebrate.
Alright. So let's So now Should we take
a look at this?
Oh, we don't get Pathfinder
or
do we? Yeah. It's in the dashboard. It's
not Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Sure. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, okay. We'll give that a second.
So if you gotta it's it's usually quite
quick. I'm surprised it takes this long.
There we go. There you go. Okay. Yeah.
Empty, say, no nothing in schema yet.
And then go ahead and go to the
home
account overview and then create
three more, I guess, product reviews and links.
K.
So product
apps
product. Let me just copy that for next
time.
And
reviews
and
links.
Nice.
So
this is
oh, let well, let's come back to that.
Was wondering. Right? This is obviously connected to
get there. So if I do get pushed,
it's gonna do updates. We can confirm that
in a minute.
If we come over to our gateway I'm
assuming right now we we still don't have
any yeah.
So how do we
how do we see we're happy with our
subgraph? We wanna publish it to the federated.
Right. So what you wanna do here
is you go to the overview there, the
left tab
far left tab, and then you can see
the subgraph section. There's a snippet there. You
can
you can copy.
Yep.
And then
but what you need first is the schema
STL. Right? So this
this is typically something you do in the
CICD,
not in the terminal, like, one ops. But
for the demo, let's go ahead and do
that. So what you wanna do is Yeah.
Go to the products of Graf overview
in the dashboard.
Oh, yep.
I I open a new tab or something.
Okay. Fine. Go to the products one,
and then copy the URL.
So take the one the the bottom one.
Yep. Yep.
And then you go in the terminal.
You can do GB, just an alias install
introspect.
GB introspect or the Grafbase introspect,
and then
you paste the URL.
So this shows you the STL here. So
you'll pipe that to schema or, yeah, STL
dot GraphQL.
It's fine. And then
you go back to the dashboard for the
gateway,
and then you copy that snippet.
And that's how you
you wanna replace the the name. There you
go.
URL is the one you use above.
And then give it the product's
name.
That should be
what you need to publish
the first subgraph.
Oh, yeah. Okay.
Oh, because I I copied the MPX. Oh,
yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Alright. So let's refresh this.
I don't even have to. It's already showing
up, but there we go.
We now have our subgraph.
Yes.
Okay. Maybe?
Interesting.
So so what happens is Oh, there we
go. Registry.
Yeah. There is the registry
which triggers the deploy. So if you go
to the change log tab,
you can see what you just pushed here.
And then if you go to the deployments
tab,
you'll see that the schema registry
enabled
another deploy. There's a deployments tab there. There
you go. So you can see that, you
know, the registry initiated the deployment. Once the
deployment is done, you see the updated
version.
That This happens every time someone publishes
a new schema.
Okay. And I'm assuming there's a GitHub action
to automate that in a a workflow.
Yes. Exactly. So another thing we haven't touched
on is checks. So, typically, you run a
schema check if there's a checks out there,
which is essentially kind of
linting
operation checks, that kind of stuff you can
do, but I don't think we need to
go into it now. But typically run that,
assuming it's good,
you then go ahead and publish it. Otherwise,
the check becomes red,
which means there's something wrong with the the
schema you're trying to publish.
Nice.
Very, very cool. I like this. You also
provide analytics,
and I've seen in the documentation earlier,
there's authorization
and caching as well.
But
Yeah. There's a lot that Grafbase is making
your life a lot easier if you wanna
build out a GraphQL API.
That that's the goal. I I think edge
caching could be potentially another episode, but
it's it's it's super
exciting, I think. Because if you think about
the fact that you have compute
that's globally deployed,
the caching layer comes with it. Right? So
you can
really, really quickly, like, get cash response times
for everyone in the world. Right? So ecommerce,
travel, logistics,
some of the kind of use cases that
use Grafbase to
speed up response times, but also to protect
their back end. You know? It might be
using a third party vendor that's legacy or
slow,
but you're doing this lookup constantly. Caching can
really help there.
Yeah.
Very nice.
I'm curious. There's obviously
the Grafbase API itself.
I I guess you build up a Grafbase.
Is that right?
Or should I not ask that question?
We're
yeah. We we we no. No. No. You
should it's it's a really good question. We
we are
we are we are in in on the
we're in the process of dogfooding it. It's
not really quite there yet, but we will
get there this year. So Grafbase will be
built on Grafbase. And the reason is because
we haven't enabled support for
yet
as a customer of Grafbase. So we're building
a Rust, obviously, and we don't support Rust
resolvers yet. But when we do, we will
be able to.
Okay. Awesome.
Alright.
We kinda took a bit of a tangent
with my link syncing there. But, you know,
we still have a little bit of time
left. Is there anything you think would be
worth showing to people before we go back
to the the talking and questions?
We never really did connectors.
Yeah. We can we can maybe glance at
them.
We could maybe try one if you want.
But we do have, like we said, the
concept of connectors and
you know, essentially,
all APIs are just data passing. Right? That's
really what it is. So we we
we saw this pattern of connecting a data
source, exposing fields in your API schema.
It's quite repetitive
and mundane, so we build connectors that introspect
your schema and then generate the API schema
for you.
Depending on the quality of that schema,
it can look really great. Sometimes it's a
bit more awkward.
You know, open API can really vary, so
I would say some of them are good.
Some of them are not so good. But
what we typically see is people use
what they can to generate, and then they
can extend and customize
with the configuration file like like we did
in the in the subgraphs. So that's it's
a really nice kind of way to just
speed up your time to market.
Nice.
Yeah. I think a good example here is
obviously you can connect us to GraphQL. But,
you know, hooking it up to Postgres or
MongoDB and getting that not having to worry
about those resolvers as a that'd be big
time saver for people. I like that feature
as well. Yeah.
Alright. Let's Maybe we
could just feature
or highlight
some of the experimental stuff. We have KV,
which is a kind of key value store.
It's built in to the resolvers.
It's globally distributed as well.
So you can use that to kind of
store
things or,
yeah, use it like Redis, but it lives
at the edge. It's pretty cool feature.
Alright. Let's be brave. Let's do it.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's go here.
So and no. We shouldn't do it. Let's
just let's replace my link service because, you
know, it's pretty useless anyway.
So
we have to end the config, enable k
v.
Like so.
Now, I'm assuming
we could
add some sort of
wouldn't be type. Right? We'd add a mutation
to store a value.
Store store a link. Right?
Yep. Look at this. Copilot's trying to get
on board here.
Let's see how close it gets. Right?
So let's use the documentation.
We want to do a quick start,
And this has given us a resolver function
to get. So let's go to set
and we get this.
So copy
And I'll just leave this here.
Yeah. We don't support inline resolvers just yet,
but it's coming. So you need to create
separate resolver files.
Yeah. This has to go in a resolver
file. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Okay. For now. Okay.
So we'll just call this set dot t
s
where we export
and
we know that we could pull in this
route
and we can get the product ID.
So we'll use this as the key
and the value I'm assuming would be an
arg.
So we need this.
Yep.
And this would be arg, and we'll just
call this URL.
Not sure if that's gonna work, but
I think that looks okay to me.
Well, I think I think both both. The
key will be an arg too.
Like, you have an input arg.
You know Oh, yeah. Yeah. Object itself or
you have two input arg key value.
You're right. Yeah. Because we're not this doesn't
gonna be it's not we're not in line
of a product. This is a mutation query.
So yes. Yes. Which
means this now looks a bit silly, but
whatever.
It's okay.
So if we go back here, what I'm
not sure is what this mutation looks like.
So I'm gonna see, is there an example
rather than asking you to get it from
your head.
Mutation resolvers.
There we go.
And we'll call this
create link.
And we said that it needs an
ID
and a URL.
Like so.
And it returns.
We actually haven't said what returns, so I'll
just leave that as it is.
And we called it set.
So,
yeah, what what is the return here? Is
that just
because we're just in a k v set.
Should we be really returning the value?
Or Yeah. Sure. Alright. I mean, it doesn't
really matter. Yeah. Okay.
I mean, if the if it's a typically,
you return, like,
you know, the payload and there's a type
within there and if there's any errors. But
for now, you know, keep it simple.
Okay. Well, we're we're just
hacking this together to test out the KB.
So
let's go to our dev experience now. So
we're going back to link
and what we want to do is PNPM
dev.
Hopefully, it's not broken.
Seems happier than I expected.
And we go to path. Oh, my camera
just went off. I
wonder if it said battery exhausted before it
did that.
Let me grab my foot.
Okay.
Better. Okay.
So we don't have anything
here yet.
So
what did I get wrong?
Well, it's a mutation, so there's a set
a separate tab
in the in the UI. You see the
Oh. Mutation. Here you go.
Alright.
One.
Grafbase
dot com.
Do we just execute that like so?
Oh, yeah.
And that's the return value. Right?
Mhmm.
So now
And just while you do that, you know,
part of the DX you want to achieve
is you don't have to think about infrastructure.
You didn't have to brew install Redis
or set up any YAML files or anything.
It just works.
In development and in production, you have KB
store.
So I guess we'll need to write a
resolver to do the k v get. Right?
Yes.
You can hook it up to the one
you have, I guess. Right?
Just need to Oh, yeah. So we yeah.
We call this length, so then modify that
resolver. Okay. And that's what need to be
a ref
link
dot
list.
And then if we come to link,
let's take a look at the set example.
We can swap all of this though
and do a get
key
as long as we provide
arg or
expand this for key.
I think.
Challenge will be I do know IT and
URL is what we do in the set.
Right?
Yep.
Let's remove this product.
I don't know. How are you feeling about
that? Confident?
Yeah. Absolutely.
Alright.
So it's just compiling,
reloading.
Alright. Let's see.
Sure. It's my fault.
Alright. Let's walk let's step through it. We
have a type, we have an ID and
a URL.
We create something here.
We have a query.
So I'm assuming my k v get is
a bit wrong, but I made that up.
So that's
probably fair.
Let's come back to k v.
And I guess it's a list.
No. There's a guest as well. Okay. That's
the only one. Right?
Yeah. There I mean, it returns.
Might need to destruct. Oh, no. The problem
is then I'm
doing a get, but my
thing here was to return a list, but
it's actually just gonna be one link stored
at the key. Right?
Mhmm.
But I think you also need to think
of the return. Like, you need to destruct
like, look at the example and docs and
what you're doing there. You're just returning the
whole thing.
You need to, like
I guess I need to return the type
with the key and the URL with the
value.
Well, you're it's expecting a string, isn't it?
Or did you change that?
Oh, no. Sorry. Sorry. This is the get.
This is the get. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
we could update we could update the mutations
also.
You're like, don't touch anything. Just make it
work. Alright.
That's okay.
Alright. Let's let's see where we are now.
Pathfinder.
But I think you need to, like, destruct
the the return still.
Missing.
Okay.
On the resolver, you mean. Right?
Yes. In the get.
So The Let's talk about the debugging. Can
I just do this?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, you can if you
add a try catch maybe, you can see
what's going on.
You need to add like, if you look
at the example, you need to add a
curly brace
around the value,
like, const before value.
Like that. You see?
Yeah. Okay. Gotcha.
Oh, we probably don't need that
until we load.
It's really bizarre.
If you could you add a try catch
around?
Oops.
I wonder if it's just delayed. Like, it
looks try try rerunning the whole thing, and
that looks bizarre.
Yes.
I will.
Is there any sort of verbosity
on this?
Yeah. I mean, it is you can.
You can add if you wanna see debug
stuff, I mean, like, internal, you can add
trace trace too, but that's pretty verbose. So
you should see.
Let's try this. Oh, wait. That's in the
wrong bit.
Yeah. I know.
Okay.
And a restart is not gonna hurt anything.
So let's get that back up and running.
Go back to Pathfinder.
No. I've done something wrong.
Okay. The the other try catch around the
whole
the whole
like, from the start of the resolver to
the end.
Oh, I know what's missing. Sorry.
I was blind. So if you you see
the examples, you need in the context object,
you have KB.
You need to get it from somewhere.
Like, look at the docs. You know? See
what I mean?
I see it. There you go.
That'll do it.
I was wondering why it was, like, red
under. So now now I should have just
copied this whole result. Yeah. That was my
problem.
Oh, wait. Well, there's nothing to get yet.
Right? So let's bring back our mutation.
Just a try. We'll just debug this for
one more minute. We don't need to get
it working.
It was just me on the web. It's
all
good.
Console dot log e.
I'm gonna do a restart just to give
it the best chance. Although I don't think
we need it.
And let's hit the create.
I'm gonna do that again to see if
we got an error.
Although, I guess it didn't set over the
top.
Oh, okay. That's a different error.
And error code of infection links, a non
nullable value which is expected, but no value
was found.
So that tells me
Yeah. This is okay. So I'm calling a
get when we should be doing a list.
Right?
Well, list returns
everything.
Yeah. But we're doing a a get. So
our resolver expects there to be a a
key.
And are you passing the key or is
it
called something else?
Is it called ID maybe?
Well, I wasn't passing a key. So that
will be the problem.
Okay. But if we if we do this
as a list.
We need to map it to the
Ah, yeah. Okay. Let's
Okay. Let's just give it the right value.
So we need to send.
And again, you should ID or key.
Well, we haven't built this into the
we haven't oh.
Sorry. I'm here to say that as a
familiar here. We actually haven't built any sort
of query that takes a parameter. So
we need our Oh, okay. Thank you. This
gives us an ID.
And if we update our resolver, we don't
want a key. We want an ID
where we get an ID and we return
an ID.
See, these things are really simple when you're
not just me being a bit gunhole with
a typey typey.
So Yeah.
If we let all of this restart, we
should see that our schema changes.
Yep.
So let's call it our create.
Tom is in the chat telling us that
we're Yeah. Sorry. Hey. Hey. Thanks, Tom.
So this needs an
ID
one.
There we go.
There. So that was a a long way
to show off your k v feature.
Finally.
Well done.
Yeah.
It is a really cool feature and we're
not gonna go into the AI stuff now.
Not not with my ability to type code,
but you do have all of these AI
services
available with a bunch of language models, which
is very, very cool. Access to OpenAI Whisper,
Llama,
and I'm not familiar with these ones, but
very cool as well. Alright.
Let's get back to big face mode. Sorry.
I'm not gonna type any more code.
I can't be trusted.
Oh, where'd my camera go?
Oops. There we go. Alright.
Yeah. From Tom. Yeah. Thanks for hanging in
there, Tom. Thanks for your help.
I'll just reiterate. Right? Very cool platform. Makes
building GraphQL APIs easy as long as you
pay attention to the docs and don't try
and make it up.
The ability to hook into a key value
store is very, cool when you want, you
know there are probably a lot of use
cases
where you could survive on that without having
to reach out to resolvers. I guess it
also provides a nice cache in there, but
there's already a whole bunch of cache and
stuff that Grafbase provides if you go and
explore that in the documentation.
We've got connectors for Postgres, MongoDB, other GraphQL
APIs, and more.
I
think,
you know, we've we've shown enough. I'm assuming
people's interest has peaked. You've already said a
few times during this episode, there's more coming
soon or this is coming soon. So can
you in the last few minutes, can you
give us an idea of what the team
are working on just now? What are the
challenges you're trying to solve? What can people
expect over the next three to six months?
Absolutely.
So well,
the news of this week is we are
launching a brand new version of the dashboard.
It's something we've been building for a while,
Complete redesign, new stack.
We're really, really happy with it. We're just
figuring out the last pieces. That's coming very
soon.
Watch out for that announcement in Discord and
Twitter.
We just we are investing quite heavily in
analytics and security right now, so we're gonna
have
a bunch of things like field level analytics,
tracing.
That kind of stuff is coming quite soon
as well. We just launched automatic persistent queries,
which is a kind of performance
optimization
to avoid sending
the operation payload over and over.
And then soon, we're launching something called trusted
documents,
which is essentially a
security enabler where you can say these are
queries and mutations that are allowed to be
made to this graphical endpoint, and everything else
will be rejected.
We just launched
the ability to kind of disable introspection,
which is also quite common in production as
a security
precaution.
Batching is coming soon, rate limiting.
An HTTP connector is coming. So where you
might not have a schema, we're gonna enable
you to just write a,
you know, simple kind of mapping
connector to a REST API or otherwise
that doesn't currently exist.
And I think that the the biggest thing
we're working around is the ability to self
host
Grafbase.
Right? So there's two kind of things there.
One is a hybrid approach where you deploy
the gateway itself in your infrastructure.
It's quite common among enterprises.
But the rest kind of tracing, observability, security
is hosted by us. And then lastly, the
ability to deploy the whole platform
in your own infrastructure
is it's a big big undertaking, but it's
quite,
popular among federal and and and the likes
who might not have Internet or they don't
want Internet.
So that's also coming.
Awesome.
Lots of amazing stuff there, and,
I'm very excited to hopefully see, SQLite connector.
Yes. And that's also on the road map.
I forgot to mention that. We are
connectors take quite a bit of time, especially
database ones. Like, we spend a lot of
time
building the Postgres connector. We actually have some
of the core team from Prisma
join us to to,
to build
some of these the Mongo connector and Postgres
connector. And even with their experience, it took
took us quite a while to to build
one that is performant and scalable and avoids
n plus one queries and all that stuff.
Stuff.
Yeah. Tough tough challenges, but I'm glad you've
got good people working on it. Like you
said, hire hire the best engineers and you
build good software.
Yeah.
Alright. Well, thank you so much for your
time today and your patience as I was
going a bit hacky on things. But I
hope people enjoy Grafbase. Go check it out
at grafbase.com. As a reminder, that is grafbase.com.
Any final words, Frederic, before I say goodbye?
Thanks so much. You know, GrafQL is better
than Rust. That's all I can say.
We'll end on that note and then hit
or set the comments later. Alright. Alright. Thank
you all for watching. We'll see you all
soon. Have a good day. Bye. Thanks so
much.